before you join me on this thrilling
journey to the truth I'll paint you this
picture now imagine yourself with your
well morold unbiased mind decided to
flip on the TV and an instantaneously
started playing the news from multiple
different stations simultaneously
reporting their truthful insights about
actual events the same real story but
told with different agendas this is what
the past man would have looked like
coronavirus pandemic
it's not entirely negative the corona
virus is nothing more than a sinister
plot unleashed deliberately by bill
gates with this launch NASA and SpaceX
got a stark reminder that one rocket
launch can't unify all of America when
you say black lives matter that's
inherently racist
what you're doing right now it's
fighting for humanity I'm absolutely
sickened and appalled by the level of
violence people peacefully gathering in
protest but we're gonna straight dead
out okay the things were so bad that the
Secret Service recommended the president
go down to the bunker people cannot
agree on what happened in bunker gate
locusts can swarm in their billions and
now we've got to the stage the most
devastating plague in living memory
locusts population under control
problem solved TV viewers need reliable
information now more than ever about the
origin of the global corona virus it's
already knew about the virus and buddy
is using this as an opportunity to
microchip people or implant a small
scannable chip and soon under people's
skin is driven as much as anyone we have
ever met to make the world a better
place
countries that don't have the resources
to pay for vaccine research many ways
should be the priority for what we do
this hospital in Lesotho paid for by mr.
Gates's philanthropy paints a picture
of the Gates Foundation to profit from
Africa but medical experts say the
vaccine is essential to Public Health
course it turned out to be total BS that
day and it's all one big lie stories are
obscured in every direction to serve
political or corporate agendas making it
super hard to get credible information
important information information that
shapes the way we think that shapes the
way we behave that forms the basis for
the passion of the brand's we go on on
Facebook and then have to embarrass Lee
go and delete them when does proven a
week later it's shitty I know and that's
where BS both sides comes in your secret
weapon to understanding what's actually
going on in the world or at the very
least it's the raw ammo you need to
appear super smart at the next social
lead distance gathering in the show
interview two people on either side of a
significant topic you then draw your own
conclusion much better informed who June
2020
was an overwhelming man to say the least
especially how divided our opinions have
become based on the information being
fed to us with the most riveting story
being today's topic Bull Gates Microsoft
microchip
could be we all seek firm ground in
moments of fear something somewhere
someone that's responsible because there
is nothing more frightening than a
threat you can't grasp well into a
world-shaking
pandemic we look to media to public
figures we trust to identify the course
according to the New York Times 1.2
million of them have come up with
someone shocking will gates bull gates
is the second richest man alive
although to most he is and always has
been top dog worth around a hundred and
eight billion dollars the genius
Microsoft co-founder now gives most of
his time to the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation a philanthropic fund that has
since 2000 dispersed over 40 billion
dollars they have always supported
vaccination programs which they claim
have saved nearly 6 million lives Yosa
spearheads The Giving Pledge encouraging
extremely wealthy people to donate 90%
of the net worth to philanthropic causes
over their lifetime hmm what's not to
like well those motives have been
questioned multiple times over the last
few decades that's got a lot worse with
this pandemic he said to have so far
confined to conspiracy land
orchestrates the coronavirus so that he
can vaccinate large parts of the world
but he's had at inserting a microchip to
control overpopulation he said to fund
sterilization programs for the same
reason that said he tests vaccines on Co
African children and then jumping out of
conspiracy land the Foundation's sheer
size has been a concern raised time and
time again so to put its forty billion
dollars dispersed into perspective only
the US and British governments give more
to global health today Gregg gonzalvez
co-founder of the International
treatment preparedness coalition
welcomes the Foundation's funding but is
concerned about its power depending on
what side of the bed Gates gets out of
in the morning he remarks it can shift
the terrain of global health the big
picture here is an accountability of
immense power
Bill Gates like many more of the world's
billionaires has the power to change the
world for better or worse through his
initiatives and influence and that's
something that should consistently be
accounted for setting out his vision of
creative capitalism philanthropy
opportunism at the 2008 World Economic
Forum in Davos Bill Gates said they are
two great forces
self-interest and caring fathers bill
claims the positive change the world
needs is via a conscious mixing of the
two with such a huge interest in the
health of our global population do you
think he's truly motivated by both
forces or do you feel behind it all that
darker forces are at play the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation is being
questioned right now more than ever
based on the global pandemic on their
true motivations behind their
philanthropic work and the effects it
has I grew up idolizing bull Gates an
inventor who the media always portrayed
as a role model businessman that gives
back something I've been even work hard
and do good but with headlines like this
I felt the need no it was more than that
I immediately became passionate about
investigating below the surface so I
started from the grassroots I asked you
for your opinion 69% say he's great 19%
say he's super bad and 11% said that
they were neutral as insightful the
information I gained from the site was I
needed to dive in deeper and call up
both sides that's a tough question but
that's why we wanted to start with it
you know dr. Lindsay McCoy the sociology
professor at the you know
Essex and author of the best-selling
book no such thing as a free gift and
then Spiros giris and hosts executive
producer for news/bad and one of the
leading promoters of anti-gay dialog to
ask the ultimate question is Bill Gates
horrified by the media as a global
health hero play me helping for the
world's benefits is he helping a select
few at the expense of others for his
vote game even though I do have my own
views are waiting to these interviews
with no agenda to do my research and be
better informed how do you define a good
person well I had to find a good person
as someone who is truthful and honest
and doesn't have any intentions towards
other people someone who essentially in
ways embraces a version of the golden
rule which is essentially do not do unto
others that which you would not want
done unto yourself of your knowledge
would you say Bill Gates is a good
person I wholeheartedly believe that he
is a well-meaning individual notice
there's much more to Bill Gates than
meets the eye
Bill Gates never graduated college he is
not a doctor he is not a Hindu payme
ologist he's not a virologist he's not a
public health expert in any sense of the
term so how did Bill Gates become the
most influential health figure globally
mr. and mrs. gates benefited enormous ly
over their lifetimes and they want to
share that wealth in ways that further
the welfare of other people so he is
very much pioneered a very intelligent
well-rounded perspective to their giving
habits and I think it's a time where we
want to applaud private philanthropy and
gestures because we're living with so
much suffering to to covet and I think
this is a time where you're really
seeing foundations and playing a good
role Bill Gates
philanthropic motivation becomes very
evident when you understand you know how
influential the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation is and this is not just me
saying that this is coming from insiders
who most of the time only speak on the
condition of anonymity due to fear of
repercussions of speaking now what are
the chances that Bill Gates and all of
these organizations just happened to be
conducting a coronavirus simulation
basically as the corona virus outbreak
was starting to take off I have a friend
of mine who is a former CIA operative
and he kind of just chuckled and said
well that would be the perfect cover for
an intelligence operation with access to
a biological weapons program basically
they have us right where they want us
unfortunately I mean I do think the
conspiracies are dangerous when people
feel marginalized and that their own
socio-economic condition is not being
seen as a problem then they might stand
to find different explanations for their
own suffering and sometimes conspiracy
theories can fill that vacuum you've
also got the problem of click bait and
that's Gates Foundation gets a lot of
hits well that's a good news then for
this video role that Bill Gates is
playing right now in this global health
crisis it's not by accident we are
seeing unfold right now is a chain of
events to usher in a new system of
control digitalized
system of control microchipping and
vaccines every aspect of our lives is
going to be essentially on the grid
we're gonna head towards tyranny due to
the fact that the media's has been
compromised they've been bought and paid
for by the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation so their conditioning us with
the new digitalized corporate
globalization what the Gates Foundation
gives is negligible compared to what
osed countries give through overseed aid
disbursements it's not should we have no
philanthropy or rely completely on
philanthropists it's how can we
structure a philanthropic
so that it subjected to more democratic
accountability so what are the chances
again that the day before the World
Health Organization declared the corona
virus a global pandemic the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation donated 100
million dollars to the whu-oh problem
reaction solution it's the Hegelian
dialectic vaccine manufacturers are
rushing through right now the
development of a brand new experimental
DNA or RNA vaccine I 100%
don't subscribe at all to these facts
and conspiracies don't think that mr.
gates is trying to financially profit
from harming people through the delivery
of vaccines which he unilaterally has
patents for he does not own all the
intellectual property this is not
conspiracy theory as far from it it's
already in the human trial stage at this
point there are any instances where
people have been severely injured by
vaccines that was funded by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation that
exploitation is not happening from
trying to harm people through vaccines
but it is happening to public health
delivery and I don't think that that
approach is beneficial for obtaining the
true health gains that he wishes to
achieve when asked if I believe the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation has done
any good I would say yeah they've done a
great job enriching their own fortunes
and the fortunes of their cohorts their
business partners in the pharmaceutical
industry but do I think that the Gates
Foundation overall does more good then
no they're not doing more good because
their wealth and their disbursement of
wealth towards select causes at their
own whim is leaving intact a system of
unfair global economic organization that
benefits the few at the expense of the
many
even the most well-meaning billionaire
is not a good billionaire because there
can be very good people but at a time of
huge suffering today I don't think
there's actually good billionaires this
has been a pretty taxing investigation
but at the same time incredibly
insightful but for now this is my
opinion firstly I do not buy into the
conspiracy theories or any conspiracy
theory for that matter well I believe
that Bill and Melinda Gates are
profiting from their philanthropic
initiatives I don't believe that the
ultimate motivation is profits itself I
do believe they wanna help however I
think the fact that the media glorifies
him their foundation as leading global
health initiatives to the extent that it
does is a problem especially when
looking at his contribution compared to
what the OECD puts towards global health
annually I believe Bob Gates is an
incredibly smart person ultimately
helping people saving lives with his
money but his initiatives need more
accountability this could be achieved by
removing the thick layer of bogus media
fluff forgetting the conspiracies and
encouraging intellectual conversations
around what he's doing we need to be
grateful but we also need to demand an
accountable process please let me know
which side of the fence you find
yourself on and tell me why in the
common
I always keep an open mind and learn
from your insights huger I truly hope
you enjoyed this week's BS and it's
offered some valuable insights I will be
back next week with a normal vlog other
than that
don't forget your awesome
winners in our dreams the total menace
come there and then start just beginners
EDC
[Music]